[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my breakdown of the new
Marvel Sony's spider-man 3 spider-man 4
announcement that they just made is the
best possible news big surprise that we
could have gotten this past week so if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's
gonna be a lot of spider-man stuff
happening this summer and later this
year whatever it takes whatever it takes
if you didn't see the news recently
Disney Marvel and Sony's top film bosses
were part of a big roundtable discussion
about the industry and obviously they
talked a lot about the inside baseball
of the Spider Man Marvel Sony sharing
deal so I'll play this clip of them
talking about it where they discuss
what's gonna happen with the future of
spider-man beyond their new sharing deal
they get really verbose with it but it's
actually really cool so would you trade
spider-man for every Leo DiCaprio movie
for the rest of you and Tom recently had
a little business dispute over
spider-man and I'm curious what was the
one thing that above everything else
brought it to I would say that there
were some reports that Tom Holland got
involved like speaking of stars Tom
Holland spoke to Bob Iger at d23 but
they liked the fact that the MCU and
Malph Marvel Cinematic Universe and
Kevin Feige were involved and we heard
feedback out there that suggested
joining forces once again was probably
really a good idea for that part of the
world that's most important which is the
fan base do you think this is something
that will continue after this I hope so
because you've shown you can do
spider-man without dizzy on the animated
film yes we have but I agree with my
distinguished colleague I think this was
a classic win win win I think it was a
win for Sony I think it was a win for
Disney and I think it was a win for the
fans and movie movie goers and the only
thing I would say about it is that you
know news cycles and the rhythm of
negotiations do not necessarily
overlap and I think that this is in the
words of Shakespeare a consummation
devoutly to be wish'd and I think we
would have gotten there and the news got
ahead of some things librarian ah I
think it's an example of the kind of
terrific collegiality that you sort of
see around this table and that we had we
had two films and four years of a
terrific relationship with Disney and a
an excellent creative partnership and I
could just say that you know we're very
very excited and July of 2021
so just breaking all that down top five
WTF style starting with number five
first big thing that was Tom Rothman
head of Sony Pictures the person in
charge of all their movies in alan horne
who's Kevin Feige boss and head of all
of Disney's films from all their brands
they were the ones last year that were
sparring for control of spider-man when
you heard the deal fall out and all the
news outlets are reporting the
spider-man was out of the MCU it started
with those two guys we all saw what
happened they even joke about how the
news got ahead of them finishing their
negotiations but then obviously what
happened after that is that they took it
up a notch in Bob Iger CEO of Disney
who's Alan horns boss worked with the
CEO of Sony who's this guy's boss to
work out a new sharing deal in the new
spider-man sharing deal is for two more
movies with Marvel including spider-man
3 which Tom Bronfman there at the end of
his little discussion shouts out the end
saying coming July 2021 to a theater
near you they're actually starting to
film spider-man 3 later this summer so
of course I'll be doing videos about
that later this year but the second
Marvel movie this part of the New Deal
is just a mystery movie that they'll
cross spider-man over into everyone's
hoping for Fantastic Four but we'll see
it could wind up being the new sinister
six movie that they just started teasing
but it does not include spider-man 4
that's right sony plans on having a
fourth spider-man solo film with Tom
Horn but they haven't said what that's
going to be obviously because we don't
even know what the full title of
spider-man 3 is going to be yet but
number four WTF in case you missed the
moment where they talked about it during
the clip Tom Rothman at Sony says that
they're basically going to resign
another new sharing deal with Marvel
after the
current one expires up to the next to
spider-man appearances meeting the
spider-man four will be a Marvel movie
inside the MCU with Tom Hahn and
potentially Avengers 5 or some other
mega Teemo crossover movie during Marvel
phase 5 you just kind of assume that
spider-man is gonna show up during
Avengers movies but Avengers 5 isn't
gonna be happening for at least four or
five more years so there's other really
big crossover movies that'll probably
happen before that he references
Shakespeare when he's talking about it
he gets very verbose with it but the way
he talks about continuing to renew their
sharing deal with Marvel the important
takeaway is that it means spider-man is
gonna stay at Marvel indefinitely would
you think is good news for everyone
that's hoping for some really big comic
book big crossover stories you want a
comic book accurate Avengers Secret Wars
movie with a symbiote saga setup that's
accurate to the spider-man comics they
can do that now if they can plan for
that now because Sony is basically
saying yeah we'll just continue to
resize sharing deals with Marvel for
spider-man indefinitely obviously
there's an asterisk there like what is
Sony gonna get out of this they're
obviously gonna keep asking for more
they'll keep battling over the terms of
the deal so number three
what does Marvel have to give Sony in
exchange for keeping spider-man in the
MCU forever there's two sides to this
Marvel gets to keep spider-man pretty
much forever which is great but what
does Sony get besides the money from the
box office profits on spider-man movies
we actually just saw the best example of
this in the new Morbius trailer Michael
Keaton's vulture character from
spider-man homecoming showing up in a
cameo seen during Morbius talking about
things that happened in the MCU a lot of
people saw that last month and
prematurely assumed that meant that
Morbius and tangentially venom two were
now kind of MCU by association because
of this Tom Hollands spider-man
crossover stuff that Sony is teasing but
that's not totally accurate Morbius in
venom two aren't totally in the MCU
they're part of what Sony is considering
their own cinematic universe you think
of it as the spider verse is probably
the best way to call it so Morbius and
venom two aren't totally in the MCU but
they will be referencing a lot of MCU
history because of Tom Hollands
spider-man Kevin Feige kind of said it
when they announced their new sharing
deal for spider-man 3 in the mystery
movie he said spider-man is one of the
few characters that has the ability to
jump between cinematic universe
so it's probably best to think of the
Sony spider-verse as being its own sort
of multiverse off to the side its own
layer of reality technically not MCU but
associated with MCU stuff number two WTF
what does that all mean and will venom
ever show up in the MCU that was one of
the biggest questions after the first
venom movie is he ever gonna show up in
the MCU but spider-man just because
venom is such a popular character before
all the Spider Man Marvel Sony drama
last year Sony technically wasn't
allowed to reference any Marvel MCU
stuff during its spider-man spin-off
movies like that's why you didn't see a
ton of spider-man stuff happening during
the first venom movie the new sharing
deal changes that though that's why you
saw the spider-man in the MCU stuff
happening in the Morbius trailer but
you're never gonna see Iron Man or
Captain America inside one of these
Sony's spider-man's spin-off movies like
Morbius but just because spider-man was
part of Avengers infinity war Avengers
endgame Sony is allowed to reference
anything that they want from those
movies in their spider burst movies so
during the Morbius movie they can
reference the blip during venom two they
can reference Thanos in the snap
Avengers infinity war the New Deal also
creates a path for more shared
characters besides Tom Hollands
spider-man talking about the new version
of Jay jonah Jameson establishing more
concrete rules about who gets to use
what characters think about it this way
they just introduced the Morbius vampire
character Marvel announced that they
were gonna do a blade reboot movie with
Moe Hershel alley Sony probably wants to
see blade and Morbius crossover in a
movie at some point but for the most
part MCU is still considered to be a
separate universe of movies from the
Sony spider-verse movies it just you'll
see them referencing a lot of MCU stuff
in the Sony spider-verse movies maybe
maybe a long term in a very special
spider-man specific Tom Holland film
then we could see Venom's show up in an
MCU spider-man solo film number one WTF
obviously though this confirms
spider-man 4 is going to be a Marvel
movie in the MCU but when is that going
to happen and what's the story that
movie's going to be and what's gonna
happen with the sinister six movie that
the Sony people keep teasing well based
on the Morbius Easter eggs we've been
seeing on the set of that movie in the
comments from John watts the director of
spider-man 3 although spider-man solo
films saying that he wanted Kraven to be
the main villain of spider-man 3
sounds like spy
man 3 will mostly be him on the run John
wick 3 style with maybe Kraven the
hunter or other spider-man villains
trying to chase him down the whole time
till he stands his ground since they've
been releasing these solo spider-man
films spider-man homecoming spider-man
far from home spider-man 3 like
clockwork every two years we can
probably assume spider-man 4 will be
released July 2023 and by that time
there'll be enough other spider-man
spin-off movies like venom - the new
mystery spider-man movie they announced
for October 2021 that we're all still
guessing about they'll have enough time
to have established more of their
sinister 6 team but 2023 is a long ways
off that's plenty of time to introduce
other core sinister 6 characters like a
new Doctor Octopus but let me know in
the comments do you want them to do
spider-man 4 as their full-blown
sinister 6 movie or do you want that to
be a different movie after spider-man 4
there's gonna be a whole lot of
spider-man stuff happening real soon
that doesn't even include all the venom
maximum carnage stuff that they're
setting up with the venom movies there
is a new Avengers infinity saga
spider-man deleted scene that I'll
probably post in the next couple of days
but there'll be a bunch of spider-man 3
venom 2 and Morbius stuff happening
really soon if you have any video
requests just let me know in the
comments below
everyone click here for my new venom 2
carnage teaser video and click here for
my new Avengers infinity saga deleted
scene thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome this is the way